hades and persephone the greatest love  story of all time at least according to  law olympus fans the story begins with  hades looking for a wife he turns to  zeus and gets his permission to marry  his daughter persephone knowing full  well her mother demeter would never  approve in some versions hades abducts  persephone dragging her down to the  underworld in other stories she accepts  his proposal of becoming queen of the  underworld and goes willingly demeter  distraught at her daughter's sudden  disappearance neglects her  harvest-related duties as she searches  for persephone eventually she finds out  where persephone is and gives zeus an  ultimatum to return her daughter before  persephone returned hades had given her  some pomegranate seeds as she had tasted  the food of the underworld she would  have to remain there for a portion of  the year the time spent with her mother  would be spring and summer the time  spent with hades would be autumn and  winter